it is about the future we're here to
show you where we're headed and the
games that we're creating that you'll
soon be playing the worlds that you'll
be inhabiting in the next year and
beyond so we're starting with a game
that we announced a few weeks ago
through our friends at Walmart Canada
[Applause]
perhaps best known for their low prices
and ability to keep a secret so let's
get things started with a look at rage 2
[Applause]
all right
my name's Andrew W K and we came to
Barney
are you writing a rage
are you ready to Ray
you're running away
[Music]
are you ready to read
[Music]
[Applause]
five
[Music]
[Music]
we
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's give it up again through Andrew W
K the perfect song for Rage 2 hi
everyone my name is Tim Willits and I am
the studio director at EDD software and
I'm Magnus niet Foster game director
traveler studios and we're here to say
that rage is back now we had a ton of
crazy ideas when we started planning
Rage 2 and we needed the right studio to
bring our vision to life
now we've admired the open world chaos
in all of Avalanche Studios games and as
we're about to show you they delivered
big-time
[Music]
well thank you Tim yeah well speaking
for everyone at Avalanche Studios this
is a real a dream to come true for us
the world of Rage 2 is perfect for our
style of gameplay but even more exciting
than that has been to work with these
guys that did software these guys
invented the first-person shooter
[Applause]
and they still make the best shooters
out there so it's been a really great
collaboration to bring you the most
insane open-world shooter you have ever
played
so rage two transports players into a
dystopian future devoid of society law
and order now you play as Walker the
last Ranger of the wasteland now you
know I can talk all night about our guns
the powers you'll use the vehicle combat
and of course you know the crazy
open-world but I know that you are here
to see the game well not only do we have
rage two playable at our booth at e3 but
we've got for you an extended look at
the world and gameplay of Rage 2 let's
check it out right now on a collision
course with earth
will extension event 80% of the Earth's
population dead
God turned his back on humanity long ago
it wasn't a war was it global warming it
was a [ __ ] asteroid
I was born in this [ __ ] parents
murdered an orphan of this wasteland an
army of mutants killed everyone I ever
loved
all that's left is hate
fear and the need for survival
see part of growing up was watching
everything get taken from me I stood by
did nothing and now I'm the last Ranger
of this way sled and there's only one
thing left to do
hello III and welcome to the world of
Rage 2 in a moment we'll dive headfirst
into the Eaton's spaceport mission where
Walker our main protagonist is out to
find a rare artifact that will aid him
in his quest to take down the authority
[Music]
approaching the even space center yes
forgot to say it might be overrun by
bandits
the goal is one to be precise you must
likely slay them first before falling
down the EcoPOD from orbit and securing
the gun take it nano tried in there in
the doctor made the space center keep
your wits about you Walker the goons
what may look whimsical laughable even
but believe me behind their playful
appearance
it sings rugged good singing dog food it
mounts on the wall its motion sensor
activated its the ruckus the crusher
talking at hockey and he can be yours
while the fire
- the EcoPOD Mission Control return
Savannah are no longer present threat
has been nullified mr. president welcome
excellent
now look for the central computer you
will initiate a recall procedure for eco
15 still in orbit we call sequence
approved beginning echo five regards
EcoPOD made no and so does the authority
sorry
get the untainted analytes and get out
also for you there is an extra bone
something that will make you uh
palatable so far here of elevator still
running so far so looks like Ranger
Walker's gonna get a bit of a boost
today
[Music]
it's like Stasi
Oh
oh hell yeah
[Applause]